who's someone who you're a fan of
um that that you haven't gotten to work
with that like maybe like
you know you you've kind of came up on
over the last couple years musically
um right now i [ __ ] with a lot of
little baby [ __ ]
which i i almost had the chance to do a
feature with him
but he reschedule it and i got in my
feelings and i said man [ __ ] that he was
scheduled
because it was about to be another big
day for me and
and the ticket was low that time now his
ticket is through the roof you know what
i'm saying
i [ __ ] with a little baby [ __ ] polo g
[ __ ] i got a record for polo g
apologies crazy just waiting to pull
that trigger yep polo i [ __ ] with polo g
[ __ ] little baby a little tj a lot of
[ __ ] who just
do that new auto-tune wave [ __ ] but like
the melodic [ __ ]
yeah but they're telling that and polo g
can wrap his [ __ ] ass off yeah
followed you a rapper for real
um what curious what was the ticket for
little babies feature back back when you
could have got it 20 bands
damn for video and verse in the studio
recording in the studio all that because
you know my engine my engineer he record
he engineered
like a lot of [ __ ] and he's
always tied in he always keep me in the
loop
right you know shout out casey and um
yeah it was probably 20 but he
rescheduling and i was like man you know
what [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and then boom now he's not 100 bands
just for the first
do you feel like uh that was like a
lesson learned like about ego
because i feel like sometimes we get
caught up in our pride and [ __ ] and
but it's not like everything you do
every ever in your career or art you
know it's like a win or lose you know
what i'm saying
like you win some you lose something
like like nipsey i waited too long for
him
and he wasn't charging [ __ ] i just
waited too long i wanted him
because he was my honestly my favorite
rapper growing up
nipsey yeah nipsey my whole section my
whole city well not well
all the asians long beach [ __ ] with
nipsey nah nipsey's uh i think nipsey
for the let me [ __ ] i first came on his
[ __ ] oh nine and
yeah for sure who think i got underneath
volume two i believe is the first
project i heard from him
rest in peace to nip